we begin with breaking news from india
where at least 22 patients have died at
a public hospital in india's western
maharashtra state
when their oxygen supply ran out after a
leak in the tank
that hospital has been has been treating
coronavirus patients elizabeth piranha
is joining us from new delhi elizabeth
what can you tell us about
this incident
hello darien so we are hearing that
there was a leak
in a oxygen tanker in a hospital in the
city of
nashik in maharashtra that this happened
as the tanker was being filled
the hospital said that it was able to
stop the leak but the health minister
said that
while doing so that affected the oxygen
supply for
the people in the hospital resulting in
22
deaths 22 deaths of covered 19 patients
now the hospital also said that they
tried very hard to
save lives after this incident the
initial
number of dead was 11 but that soon
went up to 22. now unfortunately
accidents in hospitals aren't uncommon
in india there have been a number of
fires over the past year resulting in
the deaths of
covert 19 patients in hospitals but this
is also happening as many states in
india
are seeing an acute shortage of oxygen
supply here in the capital delhi we've
had delhi's leaders pleading with the
central government
to provide oxygen for hospitals which
have said that they're going to run out
in a matter of hours one of delhi's
biggest private hospitals which received
oxygen on
tuesday night after raising the alarm
about the shortages told us that they
have received oxygen but now it's only
they only have enough supply to last
them
until thursday morning elsewhere in the
country we are seeing many reports of
people
dying because they haven't been able to
get oxygen
and we've had on wednesday
reports it's come to light rather that
india exported double the amount of
oxygen
in the past year than the previous year
and it's now in a situation
where it's having to import oxygen
because of the
shortages as more and more people are
hospitalized
with the huge rise in cases that we're
currently seeing
and elizabeth what is the response from
the central government to all of this
and
have they said anything about this
latest incident
so this has just happened about an hour
ago we haven't heard from the central
government but local authorities
in maharashtra have said that they are
going to investigate what happened
and hold whoever is responsible to
account this is what we hear
after other accidents including those at
hospitals we heard from prime minister
narendra modi about what is happening in
the country he addressed the nation
on tuesday and he said that india is
facing
a storm but that a lockdown
has to be the absolute last resort
but despite him saying that we're seeing
many restrictions come into place
in many other parts of the country delhi
where we are
has very strict restrictions they're
calling it a curfew but it is all the
same
conditions as during the nationwide
lockdown last year where people aren't
allowed to leave their home
unless it's for essential suppliers to
get essential supplies or if they work
in essential services
the worst effect at stake maharashtra
where the
incident with the oxygen tanker leakage
happened they are considering a complete
lockdown putting 120
million of its people under a complete
lockdown maharashtra is going to
decide about that on on on wednesday but
for now the government is and prime
minister narendra modi
um they're asking people to do
their bit to stay indoors as much as
possible but ruling out a nationwide
lockdown to deal with this
second wave and elizabeth as well as the
health system buckling as you're
describing we also hear that
crematoriums
are struggling to cope
around the country we have crematoriums
and burial grounds working
day and night we're seeing pictures of
dead bodies piling up outside of
hospitals because freezes
are full in india the funerals are held
very very soon after deaths and that is
because of the very
warm temperature because of a shortage
of freezing facilities but families of
victims are having to
wait for a very long time people are
being cremated outside of assigned
cremation grounds
the state of karnataka has ordered
public ground be made available because
of the rise in cremations we have
reports
in the state of gujarat where
crematoriums
have been working for so long without a
break that
metal parts and furnaces are starting to
melt and
also in the state of gujarat and also in
madhya pradesh there are
many reports especially from local media
where the official
death toll does not add up is nowhere
near the number of clover 19 patients
who are dying
in hospitals and the number of clover 19
patients who are being cremated or
buried
okay very worrying situation uh for the
time being elizabeth thank you so much
for that update from new delhi
well anand ban is a physician
specializing in bioethics and global
health policy and he told us earlier the
government has failed to prepare
by enhancing oxygen supplies after the
first covert 19 wave in india ended
last year i think uh you know when when
oxygen supply was planned
planned last year this was probably
keeping in mind the local demand the
local demand has really peaked
over the last few weeks and i think what
we are seeing now
is perhaps not uh enough forecasting of
that kind of a need you know we have an
acute situation right now
in many states and that also means that
within the country there is
uh an inability to be able to provide
oxygen to areas because almost every
state is now clamoring for more supply
you know we went through almost uh two
to three months of
cases uh going down uh you know
we we had a lucky break in that sense
but given global experience
i think there was always the chance that
we would again see a resurgence
and the resurgence this year has been
much more sharper than last year
so unfortunately it seems to be the case
that the lessons from last year perhaps
were not registered adequately
the recognition that those who need
admission certainly need oxygen and if
the number of cases who were admitted
would increase exponentially as we are
seeing right now
that there would be a possibility of
shortage of oxygen this would have been
something that
policy makers and health systems
officials should have
thought through unfortunately it seems
to be the case that
not enough was done in advance and now
we are again in a situation where
it's almost on a day-to-day basis that
planning for oxygen supply is being done
there is a lot of reluctance to go down
either with a
national lockdown or statewide lockdown
that having been said many
governments have already started that
process they might not call it a
lockdown they sometimes call it a curfew
etc
but there is a recognition that there is
a huge amount of strain on the health
system in many parts of india
and we need to bring down the number of
cases otherwise it could reach breaking
point